do you think Hollywood is made up of a
large group of class clowns who you all
class violence growing up
well we want to introverted one watching
from afar interesting but silently thank
you judging you I think that Hollywood
is made up of every single type of
person I don't think that that that I
think that that's why we go to see
movies I think that we don't or you know
watch TV everybody's different you know
and I think that um I think for the most
part people in Hollywood have learned
that they that are a little bit they
have to be energetic you know and but
that doesn't necessarily I haven't
reverse here I think that I think
there's every type here you know I think
that that's why I think that that's why
there's diversity I'm Joey Kern and I
approve this message
I'm Julia and I approve Hollywood yeah
what do you think Chris you've anything
to add you don't have any friends you're
really gonna get out there yeah what
would you know do dude this is a lot
talking I'm done here that is first time
people don't honor your local court
still work yeah this sword you know what
I need to be don't get drunk
um yeah I think that there's I agree I
mean it's just cheesy as it was phrased
I think it's this Jeff Inouye this true
that it is made up of look there's a
wide variety of people here there are a
lot of it's what's interesting to me is
that I sometimes find that there are
different types of people who will look
down on another group of people for
their motivations and doing what they're
doing in the entertainment industry
there are a lot of class clowns there
are a lot of people who are just like
look at me I just want people to look at
me I just want to be looked at and
admired and loved and then there are
people who are stereotypically a little
bit more introverted and are that say I
don't you know I want to make good work
I want to make challenging truth
we'll work and it's not about who's
looking at me it's about what I'm
bringing forward and I often find that
the people who feel that way about truth
and beauty and being you know honest and
I always look down on those people who
are just like I just wanna I'm just
trying to have a good time and the
people are trying to have a good time
always looking down on the people who
are just trying to sort of pull
something out of the muck and it's it's
well it's trying to keep it in the same
vein yeah I didn't want it I didn't want
to leap off too far I just you know weed
gets you to go to cut this together at
some point
what that tracks maybe I can take you
with you might but yeah I don't know
where it's going with that well you said
that you feel that Hollywood respects
people that are really almost we were
extroverts that are just like on level
10 and what if you're in a mood where
you're not in that space at all you're
almost like negative 10
introverted right how do you psych
yourself out how do you get into that
mode without alcohol
I think there's any way to answer that
question be more sleep don't go don't go
outside of your house I recommend in Los
Angeles never to leave your hand about
drugs or alcohol ever you'll really hurt
yourself it's pretty bad out there it's
really horrible
you should be pretty medicated medicated
maybe and I think that's that's part of
our job you know and main part of our
job is to is to I think our job is to
fulfill what the writer has written in
so and so if the the job is to you know
this character is supposed to be you
know
energetic and number 10 at a 10 and
you're feel like you know that day for
the audition for the common a negative
10 that's why we you know that's why we
studied acting you know and not that you
have to but I think that that's the user
technique to get to that place where
you're like okay you know what I'm not
feeling this today but I'm gonna go
through these steps though you know this
in my process to try to get me to that
place would you think yeah no I think I
think that's right yeah that's why
that's the that's the that's the
professional element to it as being a
pro there's a lot of times you don't
feel like you want to be
it's a weird job there's a lot of times
you not only do not feel like I don't
have the energy to do this to go out and
you know and play a scene we're on this
laughs a funny guy who's making
everybody in the room laugh not only do
I not feel like doing that someday she's
like I don't want anyone to look at me
today I just want to crawl under a hole
and put a blanket over my head and and
you've got people fixing your hair and
they're doing it it's just there's the
room you know I'm sitting and everything
goes quiet and the cameras rolling and
the eyes of not all they're not only all
the people in the scene but the whole
crew is just sort of being like waiting
for the scene to take place it's really
it's pretty it can it can be a very
invasive and and bad feeling sometimes
and you know part of being a pro where
you just have to kind of suck it up and
do it anyway yeah I want to say though I
think that working is actually vacation
for me you know when I'm when I'm not
working when I'm unemployed that's
really when that my work starts you know
that's when I have to try to get it and
that's what I have to like you know
focus on getting a job and this that's
tough you know like being unemployed as
an actor those times it's awful it's
tough and so when I actually do work
that's when I kind of relax and just
have fun and like this is what I this is
what I want to do you know I this is why
I I go through those those those
grueling times of not working you know
and so for me that's just that's just
that's the that's the
you know whenever I do get the chance to
actually work it's great
you